[Música]
contigo aprendió somos novios son
algunos de los temas más reconocidos de
armando manzanero un músico que marcó
una época
el cantautor compositor y productor
yucateco arrancó su carrera por la
década de los 50 pero el entorno en el
que creció ya emanaba arte por todos sus
rincones
minute de canciones con unas letras
maravillosas con las músicas exquisitas
efe con mí todos los días leí padre el
trovador hermoso un trabajador delicioso
que a todo el mundo le caía bien su
mejor carta de presentación es sin duda
su obra de su puño y letra' han salido
cerca de 600 canciones decenas de ellas
han adquirido fama internacional
las letras de manzanero han sido
interpretadas por artistas como elvis
presley louis miguel o rafael e incluso
el estadounidense tony bennett cantó su
esta tarde vi llover' junto a alejandro
sanz la leyenda mexicana con una docena
de discos en su haber ha inspirado
además a músicos como carlos santana o
el grupo maná la academia reconoció su
trayectoria en 2014 otorgándole el
grammy a la carrera artística hoy el
olimpo de la música tiene armando
manzanero como un ilustre más en sus
electrónicos
no hay data personal
es solo al corazón que desayunan por ese
derecho
en el café de la mañana
la canción de la semana
que muchas veces y otras veces
me enloquece
[Música]